être un hulk demande de l'équilibre
[Musique]
c'est facile
petit punk
donc je suis clairement en train de le clouer à toutes ces
choses quand vais-je un jour utiliser ça
comme avocat jen quand tu as des pouvoirs
comme ça c'est comme mettre une cible sur
ton dos  dans le dos de toutes les personnes qui
vous tiennent à cœur oh cool encore une autre façon dont
ma vie a grandi merci bruce d'accord
tout ce que j'ai fait c'est de vous montrer les
inconvénients d'être un hulk mais il y
a quelques avantages que
notre corps métabolise l'alcool à un
taux incroyablement rapide,
ce qui signifie
que nous pouvons boire autant et ne pas nous
saouler
tout le monde ne vomit pas,
c'est bon
jennifer walters est une avocate qui a
accidentellement pris le sang de la carcasse
et est devenue comme un trou de poussin une
she-hulk exactement
[Musique]
c'est  a une belle bague à ce nom
mieux vaut ne pas coller
il y a quelque chose de si surréaliste et de si
drôle à propos d'un géant de six pieds sept pouces
dans la salle d'audience
il s'agissait de mettre un vrai être humain
dans ces situations absurdes
c'est aussi cool et énervé que nous
ca  n sors avec une fille ton cul a l'air
fou en ce moment
c'est quelque chose que tu penses savoir
qui est la loi montre
et quelque chose que tu penses savoir
qui est merveille montre fracasser ensemble
ce spectacle est tellement amusant tout a cette
langue dans la langue
-chose autoréférentielle qui se passe dans les
bandes dessinées, elle a brisé le quatrième mur et était
super méta,
je veux juste m'assurer que vous ne
pensez pas que c'est l'un de ces camées chaque
semaine, sauf bruce
et blonsky
et faux
elle a passé tout ce temps à devenir
avocate et cette idée d'être un
super
-héros ne lui plaît pas
être un super-héros est un procès par le feu
oh je ne suis pas un super-héros je veux juste être
un avocat anonyme normal il n'y a
pas de retour à  ce que tu étais avant
qui va protéger le monde
si ce n'est pas des gens comme toi
cela élargit la définition de ce
que peut être une production de Marvel Studios
c'est une émission révolutionnaire radicale pouvons-
nous prendre des photos s'il vous plaît c'est une
urgence
vous